ce que vous souhaitiez anne elisabeth
blateau et oui assez kiwi c'est la jeune
femme de scène de ménage c'est ma bien
bricoler la cub mécano exact joué ma
dans scènes de ménages
exactement merci fait un beau duo tous
les deux là c'est sûr qu'il aurait pu
finir ensemble ça aurait été votre style
france review et moi je ne suis pas le
sien mais si pro vous n'êtes pas le sait
la question ah oui déjà et on s'apprécie
beaucoup d'états cantonnés sur est après
john et direct alors elle aurait
physiquement agressé des pompiers venus
à son secours et insulté des policiers
arrivés en renfort en fait je le dis
depuis que l'histoire
les pompiers intervenaient dans la nuit
de jeudi à vendredi au domicile de la
comédienne car elle craignait de
souffrir d'un traumatisme crânien et je
vous racontais tout ce qui s'est passé
après parce qu'elle n'a pas infirmé les
faits parce qu'elle s'est excusé
regardez pour ceux qui ne la connaissent
pas c'est elle anne élisabeth le nom là
les pôles extrêmes atteints il n'ya pas
d'extrait même si j'adore parce qu'il me
met des extraits et là il me dit on n'a
pas d'argent il n'ya pas l'extrait donc
voilà elles créditent souffrir d'un
traumatisme crânien de la plaie qui
d'après closer anne-elisabeth donc été
ivre quand les secours sont arrivés et
elle serait devenue agressive en les
entendant qualifié son traumatisme de
bénin la jeune femme aurait traités de
sales nazis les policiers de la bac
avant d'être emmené en garde à vue elle
va devoir s'en expliquer devant la
justice et elle s'est excusée elle a
tenu à s'excuser sur un stade
aujourd'hui dans la nuit du 5 au 6
septembre dans un bar sous l'effet d'une
forte consommation d'alcool
j'ai eu un comportement inacceptable à
l'encontre de plusieurs personnes dont
des pompiers venus pour m'aider vous
voyez que doc gynéco ne veut pas
entendre cette histoire je leur adresse
à tous mais plus de plates et ses
sincères excuses
j'ai honte de n'avoir été que l'ombre de
moi même honte d'avoir eu une attitude
exécrable je leur demande de me
pardonner
comme je vous demande pardon à vous tous
qui me soutenaient et me donner
l'énergie de remonter cette pente
à bientôt qu'est-ce que oui oui françois
diot oui mais moi je la connais un peu
j'ai animé un débat avec l as cannes et
je peux vous dire dans certes on ne fait
pas on étrangle non pas au fait pas mine
d
anglet une femme pompier comme l a fait
mais en tous les cas je peux vous dire
c'est une femme adorable qui est certes
un peu cash mais qui est une comédienne
super très caché un comportement
intolérable effectivement on peut les
reconnaître le mérite de l'honnêteté de
la perse parce qu'il y en a peu dans son
cas qui aurait reconnu avoir un vrai
show d'accord fortement marei foot avoue
ont reconnu leur consommation d'alcool
elle est quand même très honnête et je
pense que ça ne se reproduira plaque
thuriès coup pensé que ça peut être
préjudiciable à celle de ménage ou pas
du tout les jours non plus rapidement
pensé
mathieu nord à ceux des ménages n'ont en
revanche qu'il faut savoir dong hwa
c'est que c'est souvent quand les gens
boivent beaucoup et la console appel que
agressif y en a qu'on l'alcool dépressif
qui sont tristes sur votre épaule yonhap
cho d'alcool gay festif et tout ça
visiblement l'alcool agressif mais voilà
derrière tout ça évidemment ce qu'il
faut dire c'est qu'elle est ce que vous
avez déjà appelé les pompiers où elle
est peu la police voilà dans la nuit ou
parce que vous avez un grave accident je
sais que mathieu vous j'étais venu vous
y voir oui est venue lorsque vous avez
votre accident
oui non plus regardée que moi alors que
j'avais une minerve qui est très aimable
mais oui c'était très bas le ménage
hamas et toutes les semaines en terre si
on fait chauffer bons joueurs à castres
merci trésor avec moi ça va toujours
c'est vrai vraiment ouest ont toujours
adorée jean-michel ils sont toujours bas
ont heureusement parce que moi je me
fais souvent arrêté tôt ce mois ci en
quoi ça vous faites souvent arrêtés non
je faisais je me suis beaucoup camus ah
ouais est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter cette histoire qui nous était
avec doc gynéco vous êtes sorti j'avais
n'est jamais une soirée vers le mans
j'avais habité très gentil bon dos parce
que je les adore à venir à la soie à
nous rejoindre après la soirée quoi donc
il m'a suivi on est parti si grave ça
prend du temps parce qu'ils disent
bonjour à tout le monde et demandent
même des photos fait prendre en photo à
des jeux qu'il avait rien demandé donc
les chocs le pas une photo la voix ça
prend du temps il met son casque par
dessus son bonnet évidemment mais pas le
fermer ce n'est qu'un match
tournefeuille la casco dessus on imagine
bien voilà et arrivons arrivée porte
dauphine je le vois qu'ils s'arrêtent et
voitures qui se garent à côté de nous
voilà une voiture française blanche avec
trois hommes intérieur coiffer assez
court je me doute assez vite sa dette
des policiers mais visiblement mal donc
ça lui vient pas tout de suite à l'idée
et du jour passent au vert et moi j'en
ai marre et doc lui mais le son scooter
sur mais qui commence à discuter qui
salue frères aux commandes
et moi je regarde dans mon rétro de soi
et moins je le voyais vraiment je
regarde plus personne j'appelle d'auxi
météo était au banc pendant une heure je
l'appelle ne répond pas au bout d'une
heure ils me rappellent ni gens me
ferais roache pas cette idée comme
c'était mouche pique il a il comment
louper la chute et non gouvernance et l
écueil simon barque et du coup déjà
mieux la soirée je sais pas comment ça
s'est terminé
ça s'est terminé comme andoque
maintenant en fait c'était la bac du 18
du quartier harry alors les mecs je les
connais en est resté on à patrouiller
ensemble la page
[Applaudissements]